I know one guy who doesn't like fact
that Ohio State is in the Final Four
he's Clay Travis college football writer
for I'll kick the coverage in Fox Sports
one clay good morning why don't the Ohio
State Buckeyes deserve to be in there
well I don't think they deserve to be in
there because if you look at the resume
Ohio State and Penn State I absolutely
agree with you totally on this I was
saying on my show earlier how those
state was in the same position that
right now
Penn State is I imagine this scenario
Ohio State is going out there they have
won the Big Ten they have the Penn State
Nittany are into or 11 and 1
head-to-head and they have won you know
those everything surrounding it the
division the conference title and
everything else there's anyone in there
right by at Ohio State would get left
out there's a zero percent chance right
and what's funny is how quickly this
thing like spiraled right so Wisconsin
had beat Penn State
then Ohio State fans would say well
there's no way that Wisconsin even
though they want the concern okay
very wise and they would say cuz we beat
him head to head so like rationale that
they want to justify a decision which i
think is about Brandt and then this is
always a great example like the
committee members are going to say we're
unbiased we treat everybody equally
you know also says that doctors and know
what drug companies realized they could
do to get doctors who are theoretically
making every decision for the best of
their clients for the best of their
patients everything else they realized
that if they gave really attractive
women drug samples and they showed up at
the doctor's office on a regular basis
try an insert drug here you know what
happened the doctor prescribed that drug
infinitely more likely and if all it
takes is an attractive but there's a lot
of guys out there like that there's a
blonde right if all it takes is an
attractive woman showing up at your
office to get a doctor who has been
trained in medicine could things the way
that he prescribes drugs you really
think the Ohio State brand is not
impacting the way that the people on
that committee are voting well I
there the woman in the viagra commercial
that's Ohio still addressing but I I've
said this before and I was trying to
forewarn my audience that this is
reality TV Ohio State is gonna get
eyeballs and and that's why I think they
struggled with Washington you know they
want to have people are gonna watch
these games go to these games and it
becomes a big event whether they want to
admit that or not it has to factor in
consciously or subconsciously you want
to see this there's a reason why Ohio
State would if Ohio State and Alabama
win they'd play for the national
championship they didn't want to mess
that up they didn't want to have Ohio
State at for playing Alabama in the
opening realm
these are brands and that's what we're
selling a hundred percent and they got
the best of both worlds right because
they can say what we're awarded to
conference champ clemson has a better
resume now than Ohio State so equip the
two in the curry which I've absolutely
no significant the real significant move
obviously would have been if you also
rewarded Washington who went out at
Colorado very soundly and when they
pac-12 championship but then who would
have got Ohio State against Alabama in
the first round and frankly nobody would
have watched Washington play Quincy
everybody would have watched that first
round game and they would have said this
is for the championship it's amazing how
well it worked out you know at the fix I
really do feel like the fix was in and
everybody wants to see they're not
saying I disagree I want to see it too
everybody wants to see Urban Meyer again
sticks Aben Alabama against Ohio State
to go imported programs that produce
amounts of love or hate and I want to
see it through I just think it's
artificial the way we got there talking
to Clay Travis Fox Sports Radio I'm
kicked the coverage don't come but we
also you know we get to a certain point
we get for it took us how long do you
get to four and now everybody wants to
go to eight and I still like the
conversation I like an argument
I want the regular season to mean
something but if you go to give me the
reason why we should want eight okay I
don't so first of all I'm anti they're
mentally anti decisions and anti
conference title games I think we play
the entire season to know who the best
team is
in all the major conferences so what I
would do is I would eliminate conference
title games I would take the five
regular season champs that is you know
what happens over the course of an eight
or nine game season as opposed to one
arbitrary game and I would then have
three wild cards and that way I think
everybody I think the season matters
even more because you know that whoever
wins your conference is a hundred
percent going to get in okay and then
also want to create the best wild card a
resume that you possibly could to get in
as one of the other three teams Ohio
State's easily in as one of an 18
playoffs so with Penn State and there's
what I would do as well then I would
play the first round all four first
round games on the higher seeded campus
game there yeah so you get the benefit
of home-field advantage the best thing
about college environments is not the
sterile zones where you play these
neutral site games it's on campus
environments so you'd end up with a
situation where you'd have Alabama
hosting a game whereas it would have
Washington hosting a game where Ohio
State and obviously Quinn's room would
all be hosting games this weekend and I
think it would make the regular-season
matter even more and be even better and
it would do away with the stupidity of
divisions and arbitrary conference
championships that are favoring teams
that would otherwise not be there but
for the geography of division so you're
an ADIS not a forest hundred percent in
the aidid category no keep stirring it
up clay great talk to you again but
always enjoy Clay Travis college
football Ryder frog kick the covers calm
and funk Sports one the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]